hey everyone I'm run Jimmy here to
announce a new series were starting
called missing chapter the goal of this
series is to tell stories that often
don't make it into our history textbooks
that are overlooked or underreported our
first season tackle stories of racial
injustice political conflict even the
hidden history of us medical
experimentation I'll take you to the
locations where these historical events
happened dig up the evidence and meet
the historians and locals who are
personally connected to these stories
many people didn't speak about it they
kind of internalized it Wellington did a
really great job of covering up a very
dark past for a very long time political
power is truly seized by the barrel of a
gun through their voices and these
stories will revisit the past to give
context to the present day a few months
ago we put out a call for what stories
you think we should tell with this
series and we got hundreds of responses
one of the suggestions we got the most
was the story of an 1898 American
election and coup d'etat in North
Carolina and that's exactly what we're
covering first we're also trying
something out for how we're publishing
this first missing chapter story we're
giving Vox video lab members early
access so they can watch this video
right now if you want to get early
access you can sign up right now by
going to voxcom slash join but don't
worry this is not a paid wall in one
week we're gonna publish this video
right here on the main channel for all
of our viewers hope you guys enjoy the
first episode